to do was watch the Discovery Channel I
guess you could call my mother a real
Shark Week Widow anything to do with
sharks or wild boar or the dung beetle
this always fascinated Blanche Dorothy
and rose there's somebody in there
someone's alive and they're trying to
coffins moving
there's no time 13 o clock hey everybody
its episode 73 kind of a paranormal
extravaganza this week I guess well
something like that okay now if you guys
listened last week like starting with
our first show of the year we're not
doing it's not really a restructuring
but we're going to try and incorporate
like some more current events like news
of the weird type of segments like at
the beginning and you know I'm kind of
gonna try to tie them in with whether
it's a paranormal or a true crime or
whatever show I mean I'm not always
gonna be able to do that I guess so this
week we're gonna do like our little
special thing at the beginning I'm going
to talk about a news story that I found
about a guy in Phoenix and the family
and they are having some poltergeist
activity and stuff like that and then on
the main portion of the show we're
actually going to talk about two pretty
famous paranormal topics both of these
were requests by two different people
the first one's gonna be the infamous
Velma's faces yeah and the second one is
gonna be chase fault otherwise known as
the moving coffins of Barbados yeah
heard about both of these a long time
yeah these are roosting these are both
very famous stories and like I said
these were both requests so we're gonna
yeah we're gonna get into that into in
you know the main part of the show
yeah but let's see before we do that
let's do our regular shout outs like I
said starting with the new newest show
of the the first show of the year now
you know we had the new theme new
opening and stuff like that hope you
guys are enjoying that and also I
mentioned this on the last episode but
you know starting with the first show of
2018 we started putting all of our
patrons and supporters their names in
the credits of the YouTube show or in
the descriptions of the audio version of
the show so that's you know kind of a
new little perk for everybody yeah we
got new
yeah and also we wanted to do you know
as we say every week if you want to
support the show please check out our
patreon at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or you can go to our blog at 13
o'clock podcast wordpress comm and
there's a little link in the sidebar to
a PayPal account if you would rather do
that and we actually had a couple of
people do that this week and we would
like to give them a shout out so we're
gonna give a shout out to Lana or Lana I
hope I'm saying that right
and also Sondra they actually went
through PayPal and supported the show
that way so thank you very much for that
yes he's painted a whole year in advance
yeah that was pretty rad so yeah thank
you very much for that and also we have
a new patron named James so hello and
welcome and I hope you guys are enjoying
the show and thank you so much for your
support it really does help a lot oh
also if you haven't seen our latest
movie review we did burnt-offerings
which was one of my favorite haunted
house movies of the 70s so go check that
out if you haven't already and it's this
valence selling like crazy on audiobook
yeah and thank you and thank you so much
for all the people that have written
like all the really nice reviews cuz I
read them all and stuff like that and
that's really rad it's right it's
awesome that some of you took a lot like
wrote like a really long review and
stuff like that because that really does
help right yeah if you who don't know
who we are
yeah you know they see that and they buy
the book it's really good yeah so I
really do appreciate that yeah and good
news is that Jenny's already started on
the second day yeah I'm already working
on this on the second volume well
hopefully I want to get it out before
summer you know I want to get it out by
a blick spring yeah you know so
hopefully like I think you're on what
you're you you're on chapter 4 I think
now yeah yeah yeah and you sure you have
the outline done and everything yeah I
did a whole timeline and stuff like that
so yeah it's gonna have like you know
it'll have some well-known cases I mean
zodiac is gonna be in there obviously
and stuff it's gonna be from 1960 to
1980 yeah these ones are gonna be about
in hand it's also still kicking ass yeah
yeah people still buying that that's
really cool and hopefully you don't have
any more codes for that one no I ran out
of codes for that one but I still have
some codes for faceless villains so if
you want one then let me know yeah and I
send you a free one so let's get to our
first little story now this is a story I
discovered I don't think it really made
the National Press but it was I found it
on a like an Arizona newspaper site that
was affiliated with USA Today so I guess
it's like the Arizona specific version
of USA Today or whatever and it actually
came about because this guy published a
post on his Facebook page with a video
and I guess it didn't really go viral in
the sense that it was like millions of
views but it was like a [ __ ] ton of it
was like 70,000 shares or something like
that which was kind of a lot so this
concerns a guy named Rudy Calderon and
he lives in Phoenix Arizona now he lives
in a house with his aunt and his two
cousins who were 14 and 17 and his
grandfather so they live in this house
in Phoenix and evidently this article
was published on December 28th and
evident at this point the supposed
paranormal activity had only been going
on for like a week okay
he says that it started on the December
21st he says now the whole family were
out shopping so no one was home now the
first thing they noticed was kind of
minor he said they came home and they
had like a little plush like a stuffed
Santa Claus and it had been in the
corner of the living room and it was
moved into his laundry basket like in
his bedroom no it's weird what it's
happening around Christmas time so
they're mine my poor guys yeah that's
right yeah isn't that strange emotions
are running high
maybe if it's the real thing yeah I'm
interested I'm brilliant
I mean he's not it the thing that kind
of makes me think that maybe he's not
bullshitting he's not really making any
grandiose claims okay I mean it's mostly
stuff like you saw okay or you know just
kind of little [ __ ] all right so that
was the first thing I was a little
stuffed Santa Claus and it was moved and
they didn't really think anything about
it like oh that's odd you know no one
was home to do it but you know they just
wrote it off like you would and he says
now the same day later on he had this
box filled with coins that he had
collected from all over the world he's
he's younger he is a I think he's only
his late 20s but he has a degree in
global studies and he runs a biz
this where you know poor college
students or minority college students
who would like to spend a semester
abroad but can't afford it he has like a
little set up thing where he you know
sends them on various trips overseas and
stuff so that's his business but so he
has this box filled with coins and he
said it was in his luggage and then
suddenly it was on the counter in the
kitchen that sounds about right
yeah and so it was just little things
like that like things being moved around
and he's like and at first we just kind
of thought it was someone's playing a
prank or you know they were kind of
accusing each other like hey I'm having
our stuff over wha
so then December 23rd he says he walks
into the bathroom and on the wall there
are letters in Yiddish hmm in what
appears to be charcoal okay now his
cousin was in the bathroom about a half
an hour before but says she didn't
notice it cuz I guess maybe it was like
behind the shower curtain or something
like that
now he's like you know I don't speak
Yiddish I'm you know he's Catholic right
or he was Catholic I think the
grandfather was Catholic and then they
converted to evangelical but um so he's
like so you know none of us are Jewish
so he's like we didn't know what it said
so he posted the picture on his Facebook
page and was like you know asking for
translations so apparently the Yiddish
word means danger hmm okay so that's a
little weird now so at this point
they're all kind of is you you did it no
you did I nobody did it okay so he's
like that so that kind of freaked them
out now a Christmas Day the two toilets
and two bathtubs in the house overflowed
with water okay so they called the
plumber who was the landlord's husband
he came and checked everything out but
he couldn't find anything wrong later on
he's like they they start praying
because they're very religious and he
said they hear somebody banging on the
front door they open the door there's
nobody there so it's all that kind of
stuff and you know then they would go in
the kitchen and like all the cabinets
would be open all that kind of stuff and
then he's just kind of like he's like I
just went to Facebook to ask what to do
he's like well I couldn't call the
police because obviously nobody had
broken in and we didn't know was going
on and we thought they would laugh at us
right and so he kind of just posted this
little video with the Yiddish letters
and stuff like that so they're freaking
out right it's interests
that they didn't call the police because
we didn't call the police either we were
just afraid that you know that they
would think you were lying
yeah and that seems to be what they
think as well yeah
it just says from his and and there was
an in the article that was in the
Arizona paper they have his Facebook
post there and the picture and
everything like that
and he's pretty much just asking for
help he's like you know can someone
translate this word for me can somebody
now do we know if there's any young
teenagers in it okay now the two cousins
yeah are 14 and 17 that's right it's for
their fortune so yes so it might be that
it might be some kind of poltergeist
activity that yeah if anybody knows this
guy have him contact us yeah his name is
Rudy Calder on right
he doesn't super seem like he would be
and like I said he's not making any
hugely grandiose claims he's mostly just
like stuff was moved around there's like
this writing appeared on the wall it's
probably gonna stop soon usually it only
lasts a couple of weeks but yeah I'd
love to see it again or maybe send we'll
send Steve Mehra down there to look at
it yeah it is kind of interesting and
like I said I don't know if it's ongoing
or anything like that I just happened to
come across it you know the the article
a few days after Christmas I looked for
his Facebook briefly and I couldn't find
there's a lot of guys with that name if
anybody if anybody knows who he is it
could send us his facebook I'd love to
talk to them yeah it actually would be
pretty interesting and I don't yeah I
don't know if it's still going on or
anything like that but like you said
it's probably something like because I
mean yours also took place around
Christmastime it didn't last very long
guys only a couple of weeks yeah so may
be over now yeah so it might not be
doing it anymore and it doesn't seem to
be I mean other than the word saying
danger it didn't appear to be
threatening the mine wrote go true
that's right I wrote it in wax on the on
glass on the way down your window so
yeah that seems to be that's weird that
it wrote it in Yiddish though yeah but I
guess this and like I said a note no one
in the house was Jewish no powerful
things or it's a hoax one of the two
well down the bottom of it yeah it is
interesting but yeah that was you know
what I was kind of searching through
Google for news of the weird for this
week or whatever that was one of the
very few things that came up this week
yeah it's goodness paranormal
it's good I think it's good to do a
current event with each show because
there's stuff happening right now - ya
know most of our shows usually we're
talking about some that already happened
oh you know it's cool to find out what's
happening right now that way if we find
out more later we can say you know what
we actually mentioned that in another
show uh yes I'd like to have the guy on
that would be kind of interesting sure
sure nobody can find him for us just
send them our way we'll get him yeah
Phoenix Arizona you know he shows up all
right so now let's get into the main
topic of the show no I don't remember
who requested this one I don't remember
who requested the other one either but I
do remember these both these topics were
requested quite a while ago now the
first one is the Belle mez phases now I
first heard about this and I don't know
maybe you people that are as old as we
are yeah remember that the that Reader's
Digest used to have like a book
publishing arm yeah and they would come
out with these kind of compilation books
yeah that's where I first saw this yeah
and this is where I first saw this one -
I have a story and I have they're
calling mysteries of the unexplained
right like that right nice and I still
have the book I have it right here in
front of my face is called strange
stories amazing facts it's the red cover
right there yeah see I still have it I
think my grip one of my grandparents
gave me this or it was in their house
and I took it and yeah and it came out I
think it was published in 1976 or 1977
so I've had it since I was a kid so it
actually has a little side bar thing
about the Velma's faces now the
interesting thing about the story that
as it is in this book and the story is
that as I researched it online it's a
little bit different the one that turned
up in the book actually no one is named
like the people that live in the house
aren't named it's kind of vague right
and in the story in the book basically
it's saying there's an old woman and she
lives in this house in belma's which is
in Andalusia in Spain and you know it's
like a little house with a concrete
floor and stuff like that and she has a
baby and the baby suddenly like looks at
the floor like hey wow look at that and
then she looks over there and then
there's a face like forming in the
concrete on the floor yeah and she like
wigs out yeah all this other stuff now
be clear face forming in the conquered
or forced more like a pitch
sure of a face forming and a kind of yes
there's photographs of this stuff it is
kind of creepy looking go ahead there's
tons of there's tiny pictures of it
right so this actually started in 1971
and even though the book does not name
the people later on there were a bunch
of other you know studies of it and
because this has been pretty well
documented by different pair of
psychologists skeptical researcher stuff
like that so the woman's name is she's
usually called Maria Gomez or Maria
Gomez peri era I'm even seen her called
Maria Gomez oh yes yes so I don't really
know what her actual name is sort of
we'll call her Maria Gomez but there was
no baby in these other stories so I
don't know where they're getting the
baby thing from the book but whatever
like I said in the book they don't name
anybody it's just like hey there's floor
there's like faces appearing on the
floor and this and that weird yeah so it
all starts in August 1971 and the first
face to appear was just kind of now some
say it's a woman's face and some say
it's a man's face you can't really tell
yourself it looks more like a woman's
face to me but whatever
so it starts appearing on the floor now
evidently Maria Gomez was very upset by
this now she says that it not only did
it appear on the floor but that it
changed position okay then it moved then
it moved okay yeah like I don't know if
while it was forming or after it
informed or something like that but is
moving around but evidently it upset her
and so she was trying to scrub it like
get rid of it now when she says it moves
you the the facial expressions move like
I started talking or the location of the
face I I mean it seems like she's saying
the location move okay like I was
sliding across the floor yeah yes just
to be clear if you're listening to this
it's not a three-dimensional face like a
sculpture it's a flat like a drawing of
a yes or looks more like a painting kind
of yeah on on the search if she thinks
it's slid a little bit yeah I'm guessing
okay now the the article that I'm
reading about it right now that I have
in front of my face says well this face
was forming this stain was said to have
moved position and says she's not saying
the expression change right and it does
look kind of creepy when you see the
things I remember when I first saw when
I was a kid
hold man that shit's creek I thought
that do like when I said you know what
yeah cuz I had this book when I was a
kid and there are a few pictures there's
there's a picture of one of them of the
most famous face and then there's
another one that's a little less clear
they kind of look ghostly if they take
you know when you're looking at it in
the context of the story you go I'm like
yeah that's pretty good free cream it is
pretty creepy looking yeah I gotta say
so evidently so Maria was very upset by
this so she you know she tries to scrub
it out it wouldn't come out so then she
asks her husband who's name is Juan and
her son whose name is Miguel Juan
decides well I'm just gonna take a
pickaxe and I'm gonna just tear up that
part of the floor and I'm just gonna
bury concrete it right good problem
solved so so they did that and then
everything was fine for a couple weeks
and then the face came back in the same
spot I guess so or in a similar spot
like in the new concrete's
so at this point like kind of word and
started to get around town and the mayor
heard about it and he said oh no don't
destroy it
oh that's neat well you know he had it
kind of taken out and he wanted to study
it and all this Catholic country man
they're into that kinda sign now at this
stage so they take the that portion out
and they like want to preserve it so
they can study and everything like that
now the story goes that when they dug
down under the floor they found some
skeletons without heads oh [ __ ] and that
these were about 700 years old okay so
maybe like a medieval type cemetery or
something this is confirmed this is I'm
not sure all right but that's a fact
that turns up in a lot of the stories
that's overdoing it getting a good tale
that yeah this is a pretty good story so
so I don't know I'm just saying that
this maybe it was a medieval something
maybe it was people that were beheaded
for whatever reason that's what I mean
it's the thing is it's like in this
price pain maybe if you dug under
anyone's house you don't sheriff is
built on it that's what I mean it's
Europe so you know what I mean so it
might not be that weird that might not
really have anything to do with it so
okay so they dug this hole up and stuff
like that and then they re concreted the
floor again and now they're saying okay
well that's got to be the end of it we
found the skeletons disc
Elton's were reinterred in a Catholic
cemetery everything's fine no more
restless spirits or whatever later so
then later on now multiple faces start
appearing not just one right so
evidently they're saying that one would
appear and then kind of fade and then
another one would come right and all
this other kind of stuff now it would be
more than one at once now this was never
caught in the act and there was no one
actually saw these things before their
eyes not necessarily no okay now as
words started getting around word got to
Germany and Hans bender who was a very
famous person psychologist came to
investigate it yeah now what I find
interesting about Hans benders
involvement is that he's been quoted as
saying oh the Bell men's faces it was
one of the most important paranormal you
know happenings of the 20th century and
stuff like that now they say that he
came there and that he sealed off the
kitchen where most of the faces had
appeared and he put like plastic over
the floor and put wax all around so no
one could get in under there right yeah
and then sealed off the kitchen and now
I've seen reports say that for as long
as three months like no one I went in
there and then when they went back and
pulled up the undisturbed wax that there
were different faces or that the faces
that have been there before were moved
right now this would seem to be a pretty
monumental yeah development right but
the weird thing is that it doesn't seem
like Hans bender published anything
about this case like he mentioned it in
some of his who's making my fires I'm
just saying this is stuff that's like
turned up okay he mentioned it in some
of his lectures he would mention it in
passing in like books about other things
or like some his compilations but he
didn't seem to write like a huge thing
about it which seems odd yeah if that
wasn't for bender yeah because he's sick
so bender was he was making the claims
that had happened he was the one that
said that he sealed off the floor right
the evidently I was saying other
people's yes see I'm not really sure
about that I'm just saying you know yeah
so then they
had some other that were more skeptical
more scientific kind of people come to
investigate it now one of the
investigations was done by the Institute
of ceramics and glass in Spain and
actually there were samples sent to them
now this report is kind of unclear
because some of them say that they said
oh well they didn't find any trace of
paint or anything because they were
looking for a forgery or holbrook you
know because it had kind of started to
get around that maybe it was faked now
they said they didn't find any paint
however some other people that read the
report said well they didn't exactly say
that they didn't find paint and also
they didn't say like what portion of the
concrete that they studied right what
like was which face was it right no it
so it wasn't super clear okay Oh whether
it was paint or not
now the skeptics are kind of calling
[ __ ] on the methods used right now
try to confirm and debunk this right now
some parapsychologist came and they
didn't think it was a hoax necessarily
but they didn't think it was
quote-unquote spirits they thought it
was thought RP right like RSP K right
yeah like like ted serios a guy that
could we got a do a show on ted serios
we're gonna do one yeah he was the guy
if you don't know that that claimed that
he could put his thoughts on a film film
like it was a Polaroid
right he could grab a camera and look
into it with a little he had a little
gem that he put around the lens right
look into it and then you could develop
the film and you see pictures of caveman
or fighter planes things like that yes
so some parents psychologists thought
that perhaps these weren't these were
kind of like an RS PK phenomenon and
that Maria Gomez the woman that lived
there was some kind of unknown psychic
medium or something like that and she
was putting these faces onto the floor
now some of these pair of psychologists
said well it's because she's usually
around when the face is you know when
she's not there
no faces turn up and they they note that
there like some of the faces have the
same expressions as her or were in the
same mood as her like I said I don't
know how that's very subjective so
there's that I have a question okay
these pictures of these faces appearing
in the concrete were they in color I've
never seen any color photography of them
they don't appear to be color no okay I
mean I only seen a few color photos
they're just different shades of grey I
get rayon brown the raised around yellow
concrete type colors yeah okay now as
you would think there have been a lot of
skeptics and scientists and stuff like
that studying this too because this is a
very well known phenomenon as it was in
our day it was and yet now what they
have discovered I think there was a
article published in 1993 and this was
actually in the journal for the Society
of psychical Research so this is not
like a super skeptical you know kind of
thing but it's you know pretty good
right now he says that the chemical
analysis on some of these faces like you
know the most famous one which I think
there's one called blue PAVA and there's
one called the bald one or something
like that I don't remember what they're
all they all have names but I don't know
remember what they all are
but he says that in the chemical
analysis of the faces there was actually
an unusual amount of lead which leads
him to believe that at least some of the
faces had been painted with some kind of
enamel okay so you know there's that and
there was also a book written by a
sociologist and he was very skeptical of
the whole phenomena and he kind of
thinks the whole thing was a hoax as
well so even from the beginning of this
phenomena there have been skeptics
coming in and even legis
parapsychologist coming in and thinking
that probably this is a hoax
perhaps for financial gain because after
a little while the faces start appearing
you know they started charging admission
the people in the town to come in and
see them
and you know it's kind of a big deal
they said they get a lot of people
coming through there and even though the
family said they didn't like it you know
they still collected the money right so
so even in 1971 which is the year that
it started they had a commission of
technicians that came and they you know
conducted this huge like study and that
report says that it could have been
pigmentation with a dark brownish
substance quote-unquote a mixture of
soot and vinegar or the aggressive
action of a chemical compound now some
of the other skeptics that have studied
it said that you know it's quite easy to
find an oxidizing agent that would that
you could put on the concrete and then
it wouldn't show up immediately there
JJ's if we take Daisy said you could use
muriatic acid you could use nitric acid
you could use and even you could use
silver nitrate which actually if you
painted something on the concrete it
wouldn't show up until it was exposed to
ultraviolet light until sunlight right
so some of the skeptics have argued that
what is going on is that now some of
them now when it was analyzed with
infrared photography a couple of the
skeptics said we could see brushstrokes
yeah so they're positing that some of
the faces have been painted some of them
were made with some type of acid yeah
some of them were made with acid and
then painted over to make them look more
rough you know clear I guess if they
didn't come out that good well I'll tell
you one thing I can draw alright yeah
and I can do faces I'm pretty good at
anime and sketching and I'm looking at
it now as an adult
all right in these faces I can spot a
lot of amateur mistakes you know you
know I mean it's as if an amateur is
trying to paint the watercolor yeah I
can I can see it now you know in the
proportions it doesn't look like it was
done with the mind per se it looks like
it was done with the hand now I should
say that they are very creepy looking
but as paintings they are very
amateurish they're like they're like
folk art yeah you see what they
you're not very they don't flow too well
they're very wooden and not they're not
real life like in the eyes they're not
life like it doesn't it doesn't look
like something projected with thought it
looks like something that was actually
done with an untrained hand that's what
it looks like to me and like you said I
mean like I said if it was done with
acid yeah then you wouldn't be able to
see it necessarily while you were
pulling right on there so it might be
kind of difficult to me even if you
could draw it would be hard to get in
the context of hey they're there they're
coming out of the they're coming out of
the concrete you know mysteriously we
don't know who's doing it they look
creepy and they are looking but if
somebody just walked up and said look
what I drew had got mannish it's a sex
yeah now the interesting thing though is
that two to three parapsychologist
paranormal researchers that thought that
maybe it was thought of graphic that it
was Maria Gomez you know kind of you
know projecting her thoughts onto the
concrete now she died in 2004 okay and
then for a while it stopped but then the
faces started up again and it was
investigated and the later ones they
think were definitely hoaxes they think
it was her son Diego doing it and I bet
she was a different artistic style it
might have been but you know because I
think that I mean that sounded Belma is
from what I can determine it's not a
huge town or anything like that so they
might get a lot of tourists and [ __ ]
like that just because of that place so
it might behoove the local officials to
kind of keep the [ __ ] going even though
the Roman who originally started it is
dead so this sounds a lot like a
Catholic thing kind of like a crying
Virgin Mary statue yeah yeah there's
really there's a religious angle on his
way of making them or like in or like
the famous one in Clearwater do you
remember that one that looked like the
Virgin Mary that was on the side of the
the window on the side of the building
yeah it was yeah it was a water stain it
was from the water being sprayed up at
the mana tree it was like palm oil or
something like that
it didn't really but it was a it looks
like the yeah okay if you were drunk and
kind of squinted that's right but really
it just kind of looked like a thing but
yeah so I don't know it's like the fact
that what what I do when I research this
show it's like like I said I had the
book that had like a little bit of an
outline and this is the first exposure I
had to this case was from this book in
the late 1970s when you're a kid it's
creepy the pictures are creepy yeah and
they don't have its you know it's only
like five paragraphs so it's not like
super detailed no names no anything like
that it's basically just saying hey
flora started appearing in the floor and
yeah wow that's pretty weird in your
imagination starts running wild right
his you know they're leaving a lot of
story up right so but the more you look
into it and like I said this has been
it's it's been you know explored by so
many different groups and it's almost
kind of like a he-said she-said
but like skeptics said parapsychologist
said you know what I mean and they're
all kind of saying different things
because there's been like all these
chemical analysis done of it some say oh
there's no paint some say there is paint
they've done infrared photography is
like there's definitely paint some
people were like yeah there was this
there was all this lead in there which
you know that's probably enamel paint
and some people were talking about like
the oxidizing chemicals and stuff like
that which to me seems like the most
likely right thing because like you said
if you like I said if I if you used an
oxidizing chemical like civil nitrate or
something like that you could actually
paint it on there and then it would turn
up later and you go whoo man yeah yeah
yeah like when sunlight shines on it
right so I kind of feel like that might
have been what's going on now the only
thing that makes me question that is why
did Hans bender say that he had been
there and he had sealed everything off
with wax and that the floor and that the
faces moved or something like that
unless somebody snuck in there really
quick yeah and painted [ __ ] on there
before he sealed it off maybe there's a
way to break the play to break the wax
seal and then to reseal it back up
without hospital remembering what it
originally looked like yeah it could but
I don't know enough about his
investigation yeah
investigation actually took place right
and like I said it seems odd to me that
if that really happened I mean that
seemed like a big deal benders why
didn't he write a book about it because
we write a book about other lesser
lesser impressive case yeah when I think
about Hans bender he was pretty much a
straight shooter yeah and you know if he
had found something you know unusual
about this case you would have mentioned
it more that's kind of what I think that
because like I said he's written whole
entire books about stuff that wasn't as
impressive as rough what with like you
know faces appearing at a floor for
heaven's sakes right so that kind of
makes me think that maybe it didn't
happen as advertised right or something
like that because I don't made a bigger
deal about it I would have thought I
think so too yeah okay so we're at the
halfway point now is when we come back
we're going to talk about the chase
vault otherwise notice is going to the
moving coffins of our beta of Zam
jumping coffins
the jumping cut like this can Japanese
yes we're gonna talk about that we get
back to we're gonna take a break and
we'll be back in just a minute
okay and we're back yes now this was
another listener request we're gonna
talk about chase vault yes good one now
this was also in this same book that's
right now in front of my face strange
stories amazing facts so I read about
this in the late 1970s now this one had
a little more detail than the belma's
phases one did but still not as many
details as you can find now but this is
a pretty interesting story
so this vault is in christchurch
Barbados in this really old like by this
really old church now the church that's
there is not the original Church because
you know I think it's like the fourth
Church that's many of this because it
was first time it flooded and it burned
down and all this other Russia now the
vault has been there since 1720 for good
although this always struck me as weird
so they built the vault in 1720 1724 but
no one was put in it until like 80 years
later or something like that so it's
just it stood empty for a low they
bought it early and I guess I came a
long time for the first time ever today
I never know when you might need that
yeah so according to the story the first
person to be interred in it was named
Thomasina
goddard and that was in 1807 now she was
in a wooden coffin yeah and you know
this coffin stayed and apparently it was
it was fine and it was just undisturbed
now when another family bought the vault
mm-hmm this would be the chase family
they left the original lady in there
presumably she's not related to this I
was gonna hit Victor yeah so the chase
family buys it when tragically their
two-year-old daughter Marianne Chase
died so like they did back then yes she
was - so they put the little girl in
there in a lead-lined coffin yeah and
like I said the original woman was had a
wouldn't go to them now the tomb was
opened again in 1812 and this was
another little girl this was Marianne
chases sister
Dorcas and she starved herself to death
I'm guessing she was a suicide huh I
don't know how old she was there may
have been more to it than that yeah
maybe she having some kind of a jest of
problems she couldn't eat and then she
started or maybe she was who knows maybe
they had anorexia back then well yeah
I'm sure they had anorexia back then
they just call it that yeah a month
after now now they put the the second
coffin in there and everything was fine
but then a month later the dad Thomas
died
now they opened this this was in 1812
they opened the tomb to put his coffin
in there and the two coffins of the
daughters are evidently like all like
not where they were left like they were
cut like standing on end and upside down
and stuff lately in the vaults they've
been rearranged right it's like the
Mexican jumping coffins yeah right now
it should be noted that the wooden
coffin of Thomasina Godard not related
to that yeah had not moved okay it was
still sitting there in its regular place
yeah I remember hearing this story about
yeah I was a kid - I was gonna wild that
all right so and you know there had been
it didn't look like they had been the
site of a break-in or anything and
apparently these coffins were pretty
heavy like it's not like right and like
one person kids like that four or five
people I had to move right now so they
say okay no evidence of human tampering
no other vaults in the cemetery look
like they've been disturbed because some
people said well maybe it was an
earthquake or something like that right
but you know that's earthquakes don't do
that well well yeah and Barbados is not
an earthly yeah it's not seismically
active so you know so they so they put
all they were like well that's pretty
weird and they put all the coffins back
to where they wanted and sealed the tomb
back up yeah now a few years past until
the next person in the family that was
gonna go in the vault died and they
opened the vault up again to put this
next person in and the coffins are all
[ __ ] up again yeah they're all like
upside down and like standing on their
on their heads what about the coffin has
it been moved
evidently not I don't think the wooden
coffin ever moves all right to the
holster now far as we know this is just
a story we're being told this yeah or do
we know that this axe oh I'm gonna get
into that gonna get into it I'm gonna
so okay at this point so the story goes
they said okay well maybe somebody's got
to be coming in here right
so they put like sand or wood ash or
something like that like on the floor of
the vault and they raked it so like
we're gonna see if it's like footprints
or anything like I said they're planning
for the next person to die yeah I think
it was a little while cuz I think like I
said it's kind of confused but I think
it's one point there was an infant put
in there and then like there was another
guy put in there and stuff like that but
every time they opened it up the the
coffins are always rearranged and
apparently no footprints no nothing hmm
right now this is pretty weird right and
this is a pretty famous story yeah this
is how I remember the story going yeah
that like every time they open it all
the coffins are moved around except for
the wooden one right let's go back to
the first appearance of this story the
first published version of this story
turned up in a book called transatlantic
sketches that was published in 1833
yes this is an old story yeah this
particular account says and this is a
quote from the book each time that the
vault was open the coffins were replaced
in their proper situations that is three
on the ground side-by-side and the
others laid on them the vault was then
regularly closed the door a massive
stone which required six or seven men to
move was cemented by Mason's and though
the floor was of sand there were no
marks of footsteps or water the last
time the vault was opened was in 1819
Lord Combermere was then present he was
like some kind of like the mayors of
that and he had come to here because
he'd heard about it right so Lord
Combermere was then present and the
coffins were found confusedly thrown
about the vault Syme with their heads
down and others up what could have
occasioned this phenomenon and no other
vault in the island has this ever
occurred so okay different versions of
the story appeared over the years other
accounts were published in 1844 1860
this published version of the story
evidently came from a rector of Christ's
Church in the 1800s his name was Thomas
or derson or Thomas Harrison that both
names are given and he evidently told
this story I don't know if he
actually published I don't think he
published it anywhere but most of the
stories come from him okay so in 1907 a
guy named Andrew Lang he was a
folklorist he got really interested in
this story and so he was trying to like
trace it back like where we came from
and he like did a really exhaustive
search and he pretty much found that all
of the accounts that were published in
this original book came from this one
guy this priest and now he did examine
the death records of you know all the
people that were supposedly put in the
vault now all the people that died did
die when they was like in the year that
they were said to have died okay so the
dates check out the genes checked out
but there is actually no solid proof
that anyone was ever put in that vault
so we're saying the people did die right
yeah but they don't know if that vault
was ever used by anyone okay so the
people died but those those coffins were
never found inside that vault there's no
evidence that they were ever put inside
that vault right okay and I'm not saying
they weren't alright I'm just saying
that this particular guy when he did an
exhaustive study he couldn't find he's
like I found evidence that they had died
yeah but not any particular evidence
that they were put in that particular
vault okay so no evidence that they were
buried anywhere else right yeah I'm not
sure he's just saying and in the time
that he was doing this study those
coffins are not in that vault anymore
yeah there is nothing in the vault empty
net okay and during the time when he did
his study was there anything in that
vault you know 1907 because he said that
he said that he had no evidence they
were ever put in there that in froze
that they're not if they're not in there
because at some point like in the story
they said oh they were sick of all the
confidence moving around so they took
everybody out of it okay right so this
guy like I said Andrew Lang he's the
folklorist he says after combing through
existing documentation to determine the
veracity of chase vault stories Lang
reported that he could find nothing to
substantiate them either in the burial
register of Christchurch or in
contemporary newspapers on Barbados
aside from an unpublished first-hand
account by a guy named Nathan Lucas who
claimed to be present at the opening the
vault in April of 1820 now the
interesting thing about this story is
that a skeptical researcher named June
nickel who he actually works for I think
the Center for scientific inquiry
something like that he does I've read a
bunch of his books and articles and
stuff like that but he goes and
investigates all these kind of famous
paranormal cases now he points out that
this story actually has a lot of
hallmarks of like a Masonic symbolic
story okay he's like now an interesting
thing is that there was another version
of it that comes from Estonia all right
that was some around a similar time
1840s something like that I think that
story came out and he said it's
interesting because it has pretty much
all the same you know story beats he's
like where they where they make a
mention of the sand or what ash on the
floor they make a mention of the guy
being buried there who was a suicide
because Thomas chase was a suicide you
know they make note of the vault being
sealed by Masons and he's like in this
story imagine what doesn't make sonic
code masonic code and that's what he's
saying he's like since there is no
evidence that he's like yes there's
evidence in these people in barbados
died but there's no evidence that anyone
was ever put in this particular vault
and that this stuff happened with the
coffins room and since there was another
version of the story that was almost
identical that was written as a Masonic
allegory they came out of Estonia he's
speculating that this story might have
got repeated you know as a sort of
Masonic new meme
yeah and that over the years the
original source got lost and so people
started repeating it as a true story
right so I'm not sure how true that is
right but another thing I read too is
that even if the coffins had actually
been put into the vault and if this
story actually happened if these coffins
had been put in this vault if they were
actually moved around when they were
opened there it's possible that they
could have been moved around by water
okay because now the way that this
particular vault is situated it's kind
of close to it's just under ground level
it's pretty close to what in fact the
the church that used to be there the
first one that used to be there actually
flooded out and they had to tear down
and build another one higher up so it
does rain a lot in Barbados yeah so it's
possible I mean led line coffins are
heavy but they might flow but they could
float if the equivalent amount of water
kind of got into the tomb and kind of
lifted them up and in the same way that
a steel ship can sail and another
interesting thing too is that a lot of
the the bedrock and stuff like that of
Barbados is limestone which is very
porous right so they said if water could
leach into this vault and then leach
back out without leaving much of a trace
right you know like I said I'm I
actually read that on the web toy yeah
and he was saying you know he's like I'm
not so he's like I think that no coffins
were put in this bothers just story he's
like however if it did happen that way
it is possible right that water could
have moved them around it sounds like to
me it was just a good story yeah and it
made the the mace the Masonic angle that
may be true maybe he was sending a
message
the other mason same over here this is
above uh yeah and it symbolizes some
kind of a Masonic ritual or Masonic
right values yeah he said because and
and actually Joe Nichols thing where he
talked about the Masonic thing that was
actually published he published it in
nineteen eighty-two you know he said he
said that the language used in the
oldest accounts to describe the tale was
laden with Masonic symbology right so
he's arguing that it's not something
that was like a literal it was a secret
thing it was like a secret message kind
of thing he said because in this story
and the one that turned up in Estonia
there's a detail in the story that
someone hammered on the wall to show how
solid it was you know which kind of is a
Masonic thing there was an arched
ceiling of the vault representing the
Royal Arch degree you know the idea of a
secret vault is central to Freemasonry
and he's like in both stories they
mentioned that the people that sealed
the the vault shut were quote-unquote
Masons I tell you what the Masons at the
Masonic angle really that's that sounds
right to me
yeah it just kind of rings true although
in defense of the tale if they keep
going to this vault to bury people and
the coffins are rearranged yeah I know
they're there any you know they're
thrown all over the place
how do you document that would that
actually be documented I don't really
think it would it would just that
occurrence would be handed down just as
a tail yeah think about it and that's
kind of something that you know what I'm
saying is yeah maybe they were you know
rearranged yeah how could you prove that
they were rearranged you really kind of
couldn't it would just be a story
they'll get handed down kind of like you
know my poltergeist case how about you
actually prove that that happened I know
it did happen how do you document that
all you can do is tell the story that's
what I mean right and I think that
happens I mean you know we've kind of
talked about this a little touched on
this a little bit on the show that's
kind of the thing about a lot of this
paranormal stuff there's a lot of it
there's no solid doctrine it's just
somebody saw it and said and said about
it yeah you don't know if that person is
crazy you don't know if that person is
making it up there
maybe they're not making a baby it did
happen but there's no way of knowing
that and that's what's kind of
frustrating that's what makes these
things interesting though but yeah
that's what makes them interesting to me
the masonic angle rings true I think
that's very like that's not very likely
it's not like a Mason was put that story
out in those days to send a signal out
to other Mason's yeah they got off on
that shits and making secret memes
yeah and [ __ ] like that and like I said
it's kinda big Phoenix yeah it's kind of
a case where like I said you you know
you go back there's a published account
of it in the book that doesn't you know
in this 1833 book that doesn't really
give a source where it came from
you know they discover it just came from
this parish play said that a church like
nearby yeah so the parish priest was a
Mason but he sends it out this is the
church you need to go to if you're a
Mason I'm right here I can help you out
I'll do mazes and things with you and
it's interesting how it happens and I
think this is a similar thing to what
happened in the case of the ghost ship
that whirring man yeah where it actually
started as a fictional story and but it
just kept getting repeated and repeated
and that and now like a lot of people
think that it really happened but it
didn't really it was just written as a
fictional story and you know like I said
the same thing happened to Russian sleep
experiment like you know the subject we
did last week
it just started as a fictional story and
then it just kind of took off as as the
original source gets lost where it came
from
yeah it happens I guess it's easier when
it happened back in the day because I'll
use some old book and maybe they don't
even have that book anymore like there's
no copies of it and old newspapers and
stuff yeah I think people tend to think
of you know the the media like
newspapers and stuff like that oh well I
read this in the paper from 1870 so it's
true but they made that [ __ ] up
and actually I think from news probably
more likely back then more likely
because well I know I although
journalism yeah I don't really think
they had any compunctions about making
things out so you have to be very
careful and like I said I found this a
lot my true crime research too is that
you have to be very very careful you
know that's why I like to kind of find
like a bunch of different sources like a
bunch of different newspapers and stuff
one of them says this or one of them
says that newspaper sometimes they don't
forget [ __ ] names right right
newspapers from the early nineteen
hundred's and I'm back we're just
notorious liars fake news generators
well they were just trying to self they
were just trying to sell yeah I mean
they the most outrageous fake news story
about airships coming down throwing
throwing anchors you know and around the
church steeples and coming down and
having parties with people and then
sailing off away and just the airships
stories were you know awesome some
people would argue well some of those
airship stories are you're basically
talking about UFOs well maybe maybe
maybe some of them more but most of them
were just hoaxes and until someone
invents a time machine and actually goes
back and sees that [ __ ] we're not gonna
know so it's it's fun to speculate about
some some people about the airship fake
news things man they all notice well hey
you know what
this newspaper over here at such and
such date came out with with an airship
story and it sold a lot of copies and
then surprisingly in the town adjacent
to it it came out yeah you have three
days later with their airship story you
know so the the newspapers were playing
off of one another well like I said back
then there were a lobbying one city
would have like several different
competing newspapers so you have maybe
got some news yes so if one had like a
big stories like hey we need a story
like that too let's like make it out
more outrageous than their stuff so
people will buy our paper instead of
theirs so there was a lot of that kind
of [ __ ] going on back come back when I
was in you know junior high we had a
whole thing in history the American
history class you know about yellow
journalism
yeah you know that was a huge problem
back yeah I've written I've written that
read yeah I've read a couple of books
about the same about kind of the early
days of you know newspaper like the big
newspapers and stuff like that paper as
far as you could throw it back
and especially if it was um you know and
I'm not saying that a lot of the stuff
back then didn't happen it's just that
they would kind of hide and they would
just make up you know all this kind of
stuff I think we talked about a little
bit on the HH Holmes case yeah then
Castle everything how some of that might
have been exactly roses but yeah you
know what I learned
isn't it weird that I've gotten to this
age and I never knew the difference I
always thought the words coffin and
casket were synonyms they're not they're
not okay
a coffin is you know the the one that's
shaped like diamond shaped like a
Dracula coffin is ask it is a square box
okay all right I was like holy [ __ ] they
were just two words for the same thing
and they're not so the more you know you
learn things new every day you go but
yeah like I said the interesting thing
like there's there's a big long article
on step Toit I think it was written by
Brian Dunning where he was talking about
the chase ball case and he said a very
interesting thing and it might have been
actually Joe Nickell that said this
initially he's like whenever you're
investigating like a weird case or a
paranormal case he's like before you
even get into how this could have
happened he's like you have to make sure
it actually did happen right it was like
because I think the chase vault thing is
a kind of a case where this [ __ ] didn't
even happen to start with but then later
people are trying to explain how it was
but like I said fine sounds like a
Masonic message and that's kind of what
he's saying it is that's what I thought
all that like I said in the article that
Brian Dunning wrote is saying I think
it's a Masonic and it was just a story
and no one was ever buried in this vault
forever not even the wooden cause of
Mason's sin analysis but he's like if
there had been coffins in there he
actually did the math and determined how
much water it would have taken to get
into the bulb and he's like and what it
wouldn't have been possible for water to
get into the vault move the coffins
around and then leach back out without
leaving much evidence okay right it
sounds Masonic you know there are some
weird structures here in the United
States yeah they have been discovered
out in the woods no explanation possibly
Mason Masonic stuff weird tunnels yeah
they go into the sides of mountains are
made by hand that end up into the little
tiny cubicles and only on certain days
does the Rising Sun shines
directly down into the internet about
Stonehenge and then they figured they
don't they're not sure when they were
made maybe 1600 s maybe 17 hours maybe
18 hours huge mouths yeah they don't
know if the Native Americans made those
or Mason's made those but they've got
weird shitty here even in the United
States yeah we don't even show on that
actually might be fascinating evidently
construction companies to come right
down and just level that [ __ ] like it
was nothing put them all there well yeah
of course yeah for all you know that my
bad [ __ ] something from the Stone Age
you know I mean we needed another
Starbucks yeah so probably probably just
a story that kind but I'm kind of
leaning toward that as well but it's a
good story and it's you know one that I
had been hearing about since the 70s so
I'm glad I actually kind of got to
research it a little bit more so that'll
do it for our paranormal extravaganza
episode of he was an extra if it wasn't
it though oh my gosh I just can't even
we should have like little party horns
it should have um if you like the show
please remember to Like share subscribe
on all your social media and all that
business go follow us on Twitter go like
us on Facebook all that normal [ __ ] and
also if you'd like to support the show
you can go to our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast and
also if you would rather not deal with
patreon because some of you don't like
it I know then you can go to our blog
which is 13 o'clock podcast out
wordpress.com and there is a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you would
like to support the show that way that
would be super awesome also don't forget
to check out our latest movie review
which is burnt-offerings go check out
our t-shirts at zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock we have six different designs
you may choose from if you would like
them awesome and that yeah they are
quite awesome initially if I do say so
myself
pushkin one up there don't yeah I did I
forgot yeah I did for the snakes let's
get one up there that I want to sneak
please do I haven't even go you haven't
even got one yeah I know it's been up
there for like a long time
yeah you should get that and that'll do
it for this episode and we will see you
next Tuesday bye
you